the jurogan experience
but it seems like the difficulty of
combat is way more intense and way more
insane and obviously way more intense
way more insane but
way more difficult to overcome and to
learn things from it's like it seems
like for
a lot of the combat veterans that i talk
to
their their experiences are kind of like
burned in their brain in some way
where it's not like you're
sure i'm sure they're stronger because
of the adversity they've been through
but also some of it is too much
and it just leaves them
shooken yeah you know they used to call
it shell shock remember i mean that's
what they used to call it before it was
ptsd but troops were coming back from
vietnam they called them [ __ ] shell
shocked
and i i mean i think
that was me for a long time
for sure i mean it was me for a long
time like did you get counseling for
that did you like how did you i went to
mexico what was in mexico
um i went down and i did ibogaine oh
um
did we talk about that the first time
you were on the podcast no i think i did
afterwards oh really interesting um
but yeah i know i went to how was that
it gave me my life back
i mean it gave me my life back like uh
i went down and um
i just got to the end and i talked about
in this book
you know i was going through my divorce
um
i
gosh i did you talk about not knowing
what was next i mean literally
you know just gosh i was just i was
melting down just melting down from the
inside and
and finally like one of my friends
looked at me and it's like he's like hey
i just went and did this
um
this is the date you're going
you need to go do this and it's at that
point like you know i grew up in
in kentucky and i i i mean i grew up
with
weed is bad right i mean all this right
you know what i mean and and for me it
was just such a
it was just such a
to think that i was gonna go do
psychedelics
right it was just like such a like it
was like a moral thing for me right i
mean it was a moral
moral um dilemma dilemma yeah
and um
but i mean it was all i had left and i
knew that for my daughters i needed to
do something can you describe the
experience yeah i mean i went down and
uh where did you go
to
well i flew into san diego and then we
just went across the border somewhere i
don't like i was like close to tijuana a
little south of that like start with a e
so um i don't know where it was
but went down there and uh took it took
dive again like 8 p.m at night on friday
and i kicked in like an hour later
and
it was it was like i was walking through
this
this um
like gloomy city
i was kind of walking through a gloomy
city like it like overcast does that
make sense yeah and i just remember like
i went into this one room
and it was like i mean i could see the
street signs and everything like i went
in this one room and i walked out on the
stage and there was like all these
people
in this room
it was like they were going by like um
you know like those old slide like slide
shows like they're just spinning by and
i was seeing these people and i was in
there and i just felt this like
discipline everybody was disappointed in
me
and um
like i see all these people and i just
felt like all this disappointment i was
like running around like going up to
people like why
like what did i do what can i fix like
how can i fix this like what did i do
wrong like i'm sorry and it was like all
these people that
that i
just people in my life like i could see
their faces people in my life that i've
tried so hard to be good enough for and
you just you hit it you ain't gonna be
good enough for them right and uh
and so i left that room i was in there
for a few hours and um
i left that room and then i was walking
through the town and
i would go up and i would look at these
like
the uh like these fuel gauges i could
see these fuel gauges and they were like
it had
e for empty
uh or yeah e for empty and then f would
meant like finished
and everything was like this far from
finished
it was like i never finished anything
and then um
i seen this like beautiful ball light
and i went to it
and in it was like my daughter's playing
and i just felt like so much peace
um
and then there was like obviously like
different moments of i never forget this
one moment in it
i uh
i just like
i almost like
oh cause i mean you could see i mean i
could like open my eyes i mean it was
really blurry but like
i was i was present right
and
i was gonna just ask the doctor
like i was like i just don't want to be
here anymore like i can't do this and uh
i i knew that he was going to say
there's nothing i can do about it
so i stayed there and i just remember it
breaking my ego i remember focusing on
my you i remember like fighting it just
like
just realizing that
that all this was ego
that my ego just
the best way to describe it was like it
didn't make me like you know like when
you drink like you kind of feel numb
this is like my soul like it was like it
was just it just like
it was like my soul had gone through a
workout
like like a workout on it right like
just an ass kicking workout
and uh it just broke my ego you know
like it just
it just showed me so much about my ego
and there was just
i just remember like at one point i was
like i don't care i don't even care
anymore i don't care what people think i
don't care like i'm i'm not gonna live
by what people think i just i remember
just like just all i could just say back
and forth was i don't care i don't care
this is why you were tripping while i
was tripping and so i was on it until
from 8 p.m on friday night and i came
out of it at like 2 or 3 p.m on saturday
wow
and uh i came out of it and i was mad
the guy that sent me there
i was so mad at i was like i didn't need
this i was like i didn't need to feel
like this i felt terrible
um
why are you mad at him
well because i was like you know you you
sent you told me this is going to help
me and i didn't need to see all my
problems right it kind of like just
brought my problems out and made me look
at them and realized that
that i need to do something to change
these and so why would you be mad at him
then well i was mad because he sent me
there and i thought he was going to help
me and i felt like it made me worse
right
in that moment you did in that moment
and then
i did dmt the next day 5meo
and it was it
that was what brought it all together
um
the next day we did 5 meo
and i was so like
i was down i was depressed i was like
upset because it just like
i just i was like gosh i just didn't
need to see all this but i don't
understand if you think it's beneficial
why were you upset at him that you did
why and why'd you think you didn't need
to see it well what i'm saying is all of
it together was beneficial that that
bible game by itself wasn't the ibogaine
well i mean no i think it opened
pandora's box for me right like because
it made you think about things yeah
but isn't it better maybe to think about
them than to suppress them in the back
your head um i mean the experience like
it just it was like an ass kicking right
like it was just like it was like the
ultimate ass kicking it was miserable
like i was throwing up i'm saying it's
good for you i'm saying like but when i
put it together with the dmt and i did
the dmt the next day it brought it all
back together right like
you know after i did the dmt
i'll never forget like we
i took you know i took the hit of it and
i laid back
and it was like i was gone through this
tube
it was just like this tube like almost
like a water slide right right yeah i've
done it and um you feel like you're in
the center of the universe or something
like you don't exist anymore it was
beautiful it was so beautiful like the
white that i seen was like
there's no white there's no the color
here that could ever do like same right
um it's so beautiful i felt so much love
like it was like pure love
it was like
how i felt
like
whenever i met my kids you know like
whenever i was there when when hatley
was born when i met sailor like the love
that i have for them
it was like that but times a million you
could just feel it it was like so good
like it just showed that like there is
good and
for me i put it together and it's like
it's inside me
good's inside of us
feeling good like like those good things
are inside of us and it's just our ego
that keeps us from feeling and being
happy
so
the ibogaine
gave you this understanding of
all the conflicts that you've caused and
whether it's
interrelational with other people or
even with yourself by not finishing
things not following through on things
yeah do you think that it was trying to
show you that some part of your problems
lie in the fact that
maybe you don't respect your own efforts
like when you when you look at that you
haven't finished things do you think
like
it was showing you that you don't have a
respect for yourself because you you
don't respect the the effort that you
put into things
yeah i think it showed me that like
yeah i mean i think it i think
i think it showed me that like yes i
don't right like i don't i look at
i look at everything
as well if you do good well that was
what you're supposed to do
right and if you like the only thing
that i've
and i still i still struggle with it
right like the only thing that i feel is
like
whenever i mess up you know like like if
i just i live in this mindset of well i
can always be better so i just you know
like i stay focused on that aspect of it
of like
what did i do wrong
and
it's a hard thing
it's a hard balance
um because i always want to be better i
always want to be
i always want to be better i want to
give you my best
and you know like i so i think that that
was what it kind of showed me was that
hey you know like
like it's it's okay to
you know you can do your best and as
long as you do your best that's what
matters as long as your intent is good
that's what matters like you're gonna
mess up like that's normal
and i think it was like it gave me like
i don't know maybe a little grace on
myself
of
you know because i just have this
i have this problem of
i
i just always want to do more
you know i always want to do more for
people
you know and it's just it's like
i don't know like it's it plays against
me a lot you always want to do more for
people do you always want to do more for
yourself as well do you always want to
do more in terms of like the effort that
you put towards things like when you say
you always want to do more is it just
with doing things for people i mean yeah
i mean
like i i don't
i mean
like the more i can help myself the more
i can help people
you know like i i like if i could do
anything in the world like i would take
all the pain off of everybody else right
like i don't i don't want anybody hurt
you know and and i just
i think that everything that i do is
about trying to
help people
you know like that's kind of what what i
i find fulfilling
is seeing people happy
well that's a beautiful thing man i mean
that's a great way to think about life
too
if
you enjoy making people happy and you
know how to make people happy you know
there's things you can do that can
enhance people's happiness